there are now more than 80,000 confirmed
cases of the novel coronavirus outbreak
what started in Wuhan China has now
spread across the globe but what do we
actually know about the corona virus
outbreak and what are we still get to
learn about it well this is what I aim
to cover in today's video
what we do and don't know yet about the
SARS teeth corona virus so I've mainly
been taking some information from this
recent cell paper that has pretty much
experts opinions on what we know and
what we don't know about this new
outbreak so let's start with what we do
know about cave at 19 as it's also
referred to so SARS cover to covered 19
or the novel coronavirus
is a type of corona virus a virus that
can cause it's severe respiratory
disease and so sauce actually stands for
sudden acute respiratory disease
it was previously referred to as severe
and it's emerged in we had China back in
December last year so this isn't the
first corona virus outbreak that's ever
occurred is actually the Third's
recently emerged zoonotic corona virus
outbreak and this is after the SARS the
severe acute respiratory syndrome
outbreak in 2002 slattery and the Middle
East respiratory syndrome outbreak that
also occurred recently so as I mentioned
corona virus well it is a virus so what
actually is a virus well it's a small
infectious agent that replicates only
inside a host cell say for example human
cells bacterial cells it that's January
it can replicate and say what does the
corner fire actually look like so the
name corona virus comes from the term
corona which in Latin means crown which
is to explain the shape of assembles so
the spike protein to see around the
outsides kind of resemble the Monarchs
crown but this virus also contains RNA
as well as an RNA virus so how does the
corona virus get into the hotel well
these spike proteins are really
important for it and so these spike
proteins have a domain which is just
part of the protein which is a receptor
binding to me
and the receptor it binds to can be
found on these host cells so for example
a human who sell and based on the
current research already available on
this novel coronavirus we know that this
receptor that it binds to is a stew
which stands for angiotensin converting
enzyme T and so what happens is the
coronavirus these spike proteins it
recognizes this ace 2 receptor and that
enables entry into the cell so the
question is can we block this into
action to be able to prevent the spread
of the virus so one bit of information
that would really help scientists be
able to develop drugs that could target
this interaction to block and prevent
transmission is to have the protein
structure of the spike protein and well
a publication came out only the other
week that actually has the cranium
structure of the spike protein of
coronavirus this novel coronavirus
and it's kind of amazing how quickly
this structure was done and so now that
we have the structure at hand with a
better understanding of the interaction
that this spike protein forms with the
HT protein but you know can we still
find a cure well other information that
has been really useful as well has been
genomic information of the sequencing
information of the corona virus and to
create christian anderson scientist
moves with blazing speeds during this
epidemic and it really has we now have
more than 50 sequencing data of
different corona virus strains have been
found in different patients and this
information is so valuable for being
able to work out how the disease is
spreading and she be a the guide design
of diagnostics drugs and vaccine the
sequencing has also shown that it's most
closely related to a corona virus
species that in infect bats so you've
got to know the likely reservoir for
this virus and it's also shown that the
epidemic has been the results of a
single spillover event and also by
tracking how the viral genome has
mutated over time we can see that the
epidemic is sustained by human human
transmission how exactly this human
human transmission occurs daily is yet
not fully understood but understanding
this would be really important to
knowing how best to prevent this by
and as I mentioned it's so far thought
to be a single spillover event and we
can tell this by tracking how mutations
have changed over time in the corona
virus and so you can survive this kind
of molecular clock to see the evolution
of the virus and the spread however as I
said there are still many unanswered
questions and so the sequencing and the
sharing of the sequencing information
still needs to continue and be shared
amongst scientists around the world so
what are these unanswered questions and
well one thing we kind of need to work
out is how effective would these
interventions be in preventing the
spreads and are they're missing
transmission pathways that we've yet to
notice besides just the human human
transmission and other locations of
viral transmission connected and more
infamous points are there any
environmental factors or human factors
that may be influencing the spread of
the virus between different people and
other important questions to address is
what is the spread of a symptomatic
viral transmission and more and from
that how long does someone have to have
the virus before they develop any
symptoms and just say what we have been
able to get from a sequencing data is we
were actually able to use the sequencing
data to generate the spike protein
structure and so it really is important
that we continue these efforts to get
sequence information out and around and
spread to people around the globe so
will we be able to find a new vaccine
maybe maybe not but there's also
potential hate that instead of finding a
new vaccine we could repurpose existing
drugs that could try and target this
spike protein ACE 2 receptor interaction
which could hopefully offer new
opportunities to prevent the spread that
we have seen starting from we Han China
see
amongst other regions in China and
across the globe and hopefully we can
prevent this from spreading much farther
but it's not just on the scientist being
able to stop this spreads that the
corona virus takes toll on the
healthcare system Public Health and
governmental authorities as well and
hopefully by uniting together and the
amazing work we've seen so far this will
get stops at some point and the latest
update
that isn't yes a pandemic but
unfortunately we will just have to wait
and see what will happen so hopefully
this has been a good overview of what we
do and don't know currently about the
novel coronavirus so as always thanks
for listening